would you go out anything you do is
photograph with these kids i don't know
how you don't lose your cool during that
i've lost my cool unfortunately a few
times um but i don't because of my kids
i try but what i'll do is i'll put them
inside i'll take them in and then come
back out give the guys a lecture these
are kids
and they're like yeah yeah okay then we
come out
the lecture does no good anyway right
even though you're elected no good
you're like oh good look we can film
this you know it's like
and even the relationship now i i see
you you're with jennifer that even
brings more attention to you you've been
through that scene where you're
constantly in the tabloids was there
hesitation on your part uh because now
you're a dad and you're just like [ __ ] i
gotta you know if i'm with her i get the
two of us together for some reason the
two of you together creates like a
[ __ ] a dynamic like i've never seen
before in the history of man
uh
was there hesitation on your part to say
just you know i can't go through this
again you know uh it crossed my mind for
sure that
well look my response to my children is
the highest responsibility i have so
nothing i can't do anything that's
that's painful or destructive to them if
i can help that being said you know um i
know that my life affects them they drop
my son off at school two days ago and
he's the only one who will kind of talk
about he's nine years old and there's a
bunch of the older boys out there doing
some toy drive or something and they
heard him go like
like
my kid looks at me goes hashtag welcome
to my life and guess what it goes into
that i was like i'm sorry buddy is the
pain in the ass and he's gone you know
i've already inflicted that on them you
know me and their mom are celebrities
and that's hard let's not [ __ ] each
other right that's a [ __ ] cross to
bear that's an albatross already so i've
i've tried to live my life in a way that
and then
you know the during the divorce they
printed [ __ ] horrible lies
uh
horrible
like what what were the lies i don't
even want to give voice to it because
then goes oh they said this they said
that
anything you read about that was
[ __ ] the truth was we we took our
time we made the decision we didn't want
to show the kind of we we grew apart we
had a marriage that didn't work
this happens it's somebody i love and
respect but to whom i was i shouldn't be
married any longer and we said you know
what
we don't want ultimately we we tried we
tried we tried because we had kids and
then we said we don't both of us felt
like we don't want this to be the model
that our kids see of marriage i i felt
like we did it amicably we did our best
did we have moments of tension did we
have disagreements over the custody was
stuff difficult for us did we get angry
yes but fundamentally was always
underpinned with a respect i knew she
was a good mom